[Music]
so today for our daily cancellation we
return to my favorite source for
cancellations tick tock now there are
some who say that i spend too much time
responding to content on tick tock
because tik tok is frivolous and
irrelevant and stupid and everyone knows
it allegedly
but this just goes to show once again
why conservatives themselves are
increasingly irrelevant in the culture
we tend to think that because something
seems stupid to us
unimportant to us a silly distraction to
us
that it must seem that way to everyone
else but that's not the case the fact is
whether you like it or not and i most
decidedly do not like it
tic toc is one of the places where
millions of people especially kids
go to get information and have their own
views affirmed
for that reason it matters even more
than mainstream media i mean i should
spend more
time on this show responding to tick
tock than whatever they're saying on cnn
or nbc because tick tock and platforms
like it
move the culture and influence people
much more than does say
don lemon so with that preamble out of
the way a recent viral video
must now be brought under consideration
here's a young woman by the name of
sarah
she made a video to tell the world about
the books that she'll be that she'll be
reading her very young son
bennett she's being applauded for this
and i am being mostly condemned for
having criticized her but you can make
up your own mind
let's uh watch the video first hi there
my name is sarah
this little cutie is my son bennett as
you can see
my son is a white male so here are some
books that i bought to help prevent him
from growing up to be
awful starting out strong we have c is
for consent um
pretty self-explanatory but it's a
picture book that goes into detail about
consent with your body with family along
that same note we have will ladybug hug
teaches the same kind of concept in a
more childish way about a ladybug who
is hugging his friends even has one
friend who doesn't like
hugging so this one is called only for
me
same concept teaching kids about consent
and things that feel comfortable
with their bodies because i'm raising a
feminist we've got a is for awesome 23
inspirational women next we have i clean
like daddy there's even a page in the
end where the whole family is cleaning
together to show that it's not just mom
and sister's job
finally we have except when they don't a
book about um boys and girls liking
whatever they want regardless of their
gender
okay so we have two major issues here
one is the book themselves the books
themselves and the other is the stated
reason
for reading the book so let's go with
the latter first sarah informs us that
her son is a white male
which in some ways perhaps is progress
at least she didn't tell us that her son
is a white female or a non-binary
pansexual kangaroo or something
she does at this point have a
fundamental understanding of biology it
seems and realizes that her son is
indeed male
um that's good the only hang-up is that
she seems to have a lot of suspicion and
resentment even towards her son
for being male now if forever for
whatever reason you don't immediately
understand why the phrase
my son is a white male so i have to
prevent him from being awful is a
problem
imagine the same thing but directed at a
different kind of baby
imagine a mother with a black male child
saying as you can see my son is a black
male so here are a bunch of books i
bought so that he doesn't grow up to be
awful
or perhaps even better a father imagine
imagine a father pointing the camera
towards her his six-month-old daughter
and saying
as you can see my daughter is a female
so here are a bunch of books i bought to
prevent her from being a shrill
overbearing harpy
would there be anything to discuss in
either scenario no everyone everywhere
would unequivocally condemn
that sort of attitude only where it
pretends pertains to white males do we
suddenly want to make an exception
which proves not that sarah isn't
bigoted but that she's far from alone
in her bigotry of course there's nothing
wrong with parents endeavoring to make
sure that their children grow up to be
good people as opposed to awful people
every parent on the planet has looked to
awful adults at some point and said my
god i need to make sure my kids don't
turn into that
i have thoughts along those lines every
day of my life i that thought of panera
bread watching the people
eating their bread bowls with masks on
at the table and i thought i
might i hope my kid whatever happens
with my kid i hope they never turn into
that
the problem is when your concerns are
specifically racial and gendered
as though you're worried that they'll be
awful because of their identity
it's one thing to acknowledge the fallen
state of the human race and our
propensity for evil
it's another to imagine that your own
child is especially susceptible
to it based on their identity that's
called bigotry
and yes to be bigoted against your own
flesh and blood is deranged beyond all
imagining
it's a type of thought process that has
been made possible by the critical race
theory cult
one of the most basic strategies of any
cult is to turn
its members against their own families
now usually this involves turning
children
against parents and crt does that too
but the even more demanded thing is to
turn parents against children
and then what about the books themselves
even many of the people criticizing this
video have still allowed that the books
are fine
in and of themselves it's just the
framing that's the problem but i
disagree
the books are a problem too first of all
she has
three books on consent three of them
that she'll begin reading to her child
from infancy
and remember she's not reading the books
in order to protect him
from being the victim of non-consensual
touching no this is all about stopping
stopping him from sexually assaulting
other people
this is a woman so worried that her son
will be a rapist
that she started him on an anti-rapist
curriculum from infancy
she might as well read him a book called
we eat dinner with people not people for
dinner in order to teach him how to not
be a cannibal
i mean she has imagined that her son is
at a very high risk of being an absolute
monster not just a bad person but a
monster
and now she'll spend most of her
maternal energy steering him away from
what she believes
is a near inevitability all you're
really doing at best is
creating an issue where it didn't exist
and introducing concepts where
before there was but childish innocence
and ignorance
by the way in spite of the feminist
insistence that we need to teach our
sons not to rape
and they say that all the time right the
truth is
no you shouldn't need to specifically
teach that
i don't know about you there was never a
time in my life when my parents sat me
down and said now son
don't be a rapist any more than they
ever sat me down and said now son
don't be an axe murderer they never said
either of those things
and yet i i became neither an axe
murderer nor a rapist
why well because they inculcated in me a
more complete
value system they taught me to respect
the dignity and value of other human
beings as well as my own
and they instilled virtue as well as
they could anyway
while warning against sin and vice and
so on when you do that with your
children
they will not grow up to be perfect
people but they will develop a moral
code and a system of values that will
direct them away from
things like rape and murder and
hopefully
it'll do a lot more than that it turns
out you should aim a lot
higher than just don't be a rapist
don't be awful and when you aim higher
when you aim for actual virtue the
don't be awful and don't be a rapist
lesson is baked into the cake
you don't even need to say it or focus
on it
especially not when the kid is still in
diapers you damn fruitcake
as for the other two books or other
three um there was one telling the boy
that he should help clean around the
house
and then there was another telling him
that he can play with whatever toys he
wants regardless of gender
those could be okay in and of themselves
depending on the specifics i haven't
read the book so i don't know
but this this mother is not reading
those books in order to open up
possibilities
and to allow the child to express
himself she has rather a very specific
and rigid idea of the sort of boy
she wants him to be she's already
labeled him he's a feminist
six months old he's already a feminist
she's decided that from birth
so although she says oh kids can
like whatever they want they can do
whatever they want in reality she has
made a box for him and she will fit him
into it one way or another
now of course we all make boxes as
parents
for our kids we all have ideas of uh
about the sorts of people we want them
to be
that's what instilling values is all
about but the difference is that
progressive parents quote unquote have
an even narrower and more constricting
box
all while pretending that there's no box
at all
and that's the real problem and that's
why they are all canceled today
along with sarah
but not her poor child who uh is
certainly not canceled and is gonna need
all the
help he can get and i i fear for him and
so many other kids
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated